[Music]
favorite song favorite mail so many
nominations tonight the most nominated
mail in country music tonight here at
the AMAs are you okay can you stand it's
a huge honor this trip photo album spin
what what you guys are hunt have done
for this record is beyond description so
very grateful female is such an
important song it's such an important
time for females in Hollywood and then
you'll end it blended you lent your
voice to the song why was that important
to you and do you have to ask how does
that happen I have a studio at the house
and we were recording that's where we go
to the song and Nick was home so I just
went upstairs and second you come and
sing on this as well Nicole galleon
who's one of the writers was singing
already and I said the great ethnic join
door so Nick and Nick has the most
beautiful voice in the world oh my wife
were you nervous though you have a
beautiful point went down no I don't I
went down and I did it because he asked
me to and he knows I have no confidence
when it comes to singing so I'll sing
for him
[Music]
you